[Musique]
95% des entreprises réunionnaises sont
des tpe et pme
un chiffre éloquent qui explique cette
foule des grands jours souvent seule ces
hommes et ces femmes chefs d'orchestre
de leur entreprise son producteur de
richesses alors les 50 ans de l'un de
leurs groupements est un événement que
personne ne voulait manquer vient de
fêter les 70 ans la départementalisation
donc là ces pme a grandi avec le
territoire et l'année et sa maman pour
regarder ce que nous avons fait de bien
ce qu'il faudra faire de mieux et
surtout partager non besson commune pour
se projeter sur les cinquante prochaines
années
la première convention de la stratégie
du grenache a qui ont été posées par
mois lorsque j'étais élu en 2010 c'est
en octobre je les signe avec le
département de la réunion que s'est
engagé à faire de la commande publique
un levier de développement du territoire
parce que quand on achète on n'achète
pas des gommes et des stylos on achète
du développement économique
l'épopée d'un entrepreneur qui bâtit son
territoire
parce que
avec la connaissance viennent de grandes
responsabilités il n'y a pas qu'au
supermarché ont fait des provisions
bonsoir à tous la cpm régnant vous
souhaite bien à l'intérieur le temps et
cérémonial toutes les institutions sont
présentes et au premier chef le
département de la réunion ses
compétences et les commandes publiques
créé au quotidien des relations avec ces
entreprises locales il ya une évolution
il ya la loi note qui a remis un peu des
choses qui soit car modifier les
compétences et après honnêtement il ya
des hommes dans toutes les collectivités
et finalement si la ferrade humains et
donc de relations qu'on peut avoir avec
tel ou telle collectivité pour faire
avancer nos affaires
les 650 adhérents ont ils eu ce jour-là
leur nouveau bureau
une dynamique d'ancrage territorial
résumé par leur affichage agi dans son
lieu et pense le monde est là et faire
reconnaître et s'en va je salue
l'engagement au quotidien des artisans
des commerçants des chefs d'entreprise
des agriculteurs dans tous ces domaines
où la vie n'est pas facile quand on est
entrepreneur
mais malgré tout eh bien il ya une envie
une volonté de la part de ces femmes de
ces hommes réunionnais à construire dans
des sociétés des entreprises créatrices
d'emplois
créatrice de richesses au bénéfice du
plus grand nombre
l'environnement réglementaire la crise
du gilet jaune les défis ne manquent pas
et ce soir là ils semblaient tous
unanimes pour le développement de notre
territoire
[Musique]